this week's honest trailer is brought to
you by dnd beyond register for free at
dnd beyond.com to start your adventure
happy holidays from screen junkies we're
working on a ton of big honest trailers
and some fun new stuff for the year
ahead but until then here's a bunch of
our old stuff strung together for
minimum effort and maximum views
[Music]
from the company that went bankrupt in
the 90s and sold off the rights to its
most popular characters comes a film
based on the equivalent of leftover
scrap metal proving that marvel can
build a franchise around just about
anybody
except the hulk iron man
experience the massive success that
marvel turned into a formula for
printing money where you take a half
forgotten b-list superhero cast an
unknown or half-forgotten b-list actor
have him fight a generic villain that
will only last one movie fall in love
with a generically strong female
character make a ton of quips talk a
bunch of science destroy some public
property cram stanley in there somewhere
have a blue beam shoot up in the sky set
up an avengers movie and force the
audience to sit through 500 visual
effects guys names just to catch a few
extra seconds i'm here to talk to you
about the avenger initiative hey if it
ain't broke don't fix it mr stark you
become part of a bigger universe
you grew up loving batman spider-man and
superman now get ready for a hero that
makes them look like huge nerds by
comparison and meet tony stark a hard
party robert downey jr-ish weapons
designer who's the perfect match between
actor and role that allowed him to spend
the next seven years making a fortune by
pretending to look at a screen
pretending to play with some holograms
doing a little voice over keep going and
basically act like himself until someone
says cut nice work if you can get it
cheer for a hero whose power is his
intelligence not some magical hammer as
tony craps out new technology the way
you and i crap out breakfast like this
weapon that's used against him these
weapons that are used against him
this weapon that's used against him you
remember this one right this weapon
that's used against him tony stark was
able to build this in a cave this
miracle technology that becomes a weapon
that's used against him and of course
ultron
seriously tony just do the world of
solid stop working trying to read the
world of weapons
you gave me the best one ever so revisit
the marvel masterpiece that started it
all without which there would be no
marvel cinematic universe
no avengers no guardians no winter
soldier
leaving hollywood in the terrifying
position of having to develop something
original
starring bruce wayne
miss money pepper obadiah vane terence
how hard could it have been to take a
pay cut for the sequels obligatory
stanio and the iron giant
marvel man
where is it wow that's got to be the
only time someone has ever looked cool
riding a segway
[Music]
from marvel studios and universal comes
the second movie in the marvel cinematic
universe that we're doing an honest
trailer for because infinity war is
coming out we've already done all the
other mcu movies and black panther isn't
on blu-ray yet
the incredible hulk
meet bruce banner no not the one people
like who's that he never played the hulk
did he now you know the one i'm talking
about the death smoochie guy there he is
ed norton shines as the first marvel
actor to show off how many crunches he
did for the part
and he's bringing his incredible range
to a role that has him act like he's on
xanax i know a few techniques could help
you manage that anger very effectively
while off camera he's bringing his
incredible ego to a full rewrite of the
script under the fake name edward
harrison do you want to get terence
howarded because that's how you get
terence howarded
[Music]
join bruce for a story where he runs
away from the military runs away from
the military and runs away from the
military again
but sometimes when his little fitbit
thingy hits 200 he'll turn into the hulk
an unstoppable rage monster that's
actually a huge danger to the entire
planet the economy of brazil
and all of harlem
yeesh i'm glad he flew up to not planet
hulk there would mean earth left for
thanos to punch
before gwyneth paltrow took a four-year
hiatus and before natalie portman took
an indefinite absence i dumped her some
mutual dumping liv tyler dropped off the
face of the mcu without so much as an
easter egg stand and smile as the
actress spends most of the movie
standing and smiling as she doesn't get
anything or even anyone to do i can't
get too excited
not even a little excited
you've always wanted to see the hulk
match up against a villain that could
equal his powers well too bad because
he's fighting the skinny british guy
from reservoir dogs he's a decorated
veteran with zero personal connection to
bruce banner and zero thread to the hull
but when he shoots himself full of
tainted captain america juice he'll turn
into one of the most forgettable
monsters in the mcu the mixture could be
an abomination that was so bad he got
his ass kicked all the way into batman v
superman
go back to the days before marvel had
this whole universe thing on autopilot
where our nerd boners would only get
little tastes of fan service a sequel
was only lightly implied instead of
blatantly setting up five more movies it
put its post credit scene before the
credits what if i told you we were
putting a team together and didn't make
a billion dollars oh
that's like green planter money uh i
know what it's like
to not live up to expectations
so strap in for this odd sequel prequel
reboot origin movie that's better than
we give it credit for because whatever
you think about the film itself it gave
us mark ruffa hulk
puny god and paved the way for ed norton
to join wes anderson's fancy boy
cinematic universe oh man i cannot wait
for the royal tenon bombs to fight steve
zisa in budapest hotel infinity floor
okay green goblin nobody punches out
flash thompson in this quirky hotel and
gets away with it
starring
i am jack's departure due to creative
differences
icky pop
like a rose you all got an iron man suit
that needs voicing and teenage mutant
ninja heroin addict
the disposable hulk
in guatemala
yeah it's probably not the first time a
white guy got so hammered in brazil he
woke up half naked in guatemala spring
break 97 whoa
[Music]
from the poor man's joss whedon
comes the forgettable follow-up to iron
man
that's essentially just killing time
until the avengers
iron man 2
the completely disappointing sequel you
fooled yourself into liking simply
because it had iron man in it suit up
for a feature-length version of the nick
fury bonus scene from the end of the
first iron man which will still be
unresolved by the end of this movie tony
stark not not recommended
we've witnessed tony stark battle global
terrorism and his inner demons now
prepare to see him take on his biggest
challenges yet
tedious government committees can you
please read page 57 paragraph four
you're requesting that i read specific
selections from my report center yes sir
corporate maneuvering it was an illegal
seizure of trademark property low
batteries another core has been depleted
and some guy with a bird i want my board
is this a bird back in russia a sequel
so inferior it will replace an awesome
origin story with countless subplots you
won't remember as soon as you walk out
of the theater a story that ditches
technology grounded in reality for
laughingly unrealistic magic holograms
loose landscaping the shrubbery the
trees
parking lots exits entrances
and substitutes jeff bridges with gary
shandling do you or do you not possess a
specialized weapon witness a superhero
movie with just enough iron man action
to fill a three-minute trailer but not a
feature-length film trust us we counted
instead sit back and prepare to watch
iron man attend corporate events eat
donuts dj birthday parties and pee his
pants
experience the epic face-off between
iron man and one of marvel's least known
villains whiplash who's harnessed the
most dangerous modern technology ever
only to waste it
on a whip
alfo with no known superpowers who
somehow survives being crushed by a car
not once
[Music]
not twice
but four five times
to defeat this madman iron man's
bringing in backup and they are all just
as boring as the rest of the movie
pepper potts an inconsistent nag who's
totally cool with her boyfriend being
iron man but freaks out when he drives a
car
this cannot happen black widow a sexy
spy shoehorned into the movie just to
establish her boobs for the avengers and
lieutenant colonel james rhodes nope no
no not that one yeah that's the one who
has the skills to perfectly fit in and
pilot an iron man suit without any
previous experience wait didn't tony
need like half a movie to figure out how
to work that thing a new chapter so thin
the key to the entire plot is resolved
by a 40 year old easter egg from tony's
dad
tony i built this for you one day you'll
figure this out who decades earlier
somehow knew his grown son would keep
his old diorama put it in an impossible
to predict holographic computer display
that can magnify impossible amounts of
detail and reveal the chemical makeup of
an impossible to create element
unfortunately it is impossible to
synthesize which tony immediately
synthesizes in order to wrap up all
loose ends congratulations sir you have
created a new element uh someone got
paid to write this starring rob stark
mrs coldplay better terence howard some
guy in a mickey rourke mask oh that guy
from um oh
he was in that one movie a guy in a gary
shandling mask vince vaughn's bff don
draper sam elliott no uh oh man it's
bugging me and hawkeye with boobs iron
man 2
[Applause]
sam rockwell it's sam rockwell that's
the guy i'd loved him in galaxy quest
[Music]
prepare for a film that only exists so
non-nerds will recognize the blonde guy
in the avengers
thor
you've seen great superhero films you've
seen terrible superhero films
now prepare for a superhero film that's
just kinda
i mean i guess they did the best they
could adapting a comic book about a
bratty space god you are an old man and
a fool
journey to asgard the land of viking
myth where everyone gets a pointy hat
the gods live inside a cgi pipe organ
and the only way in or out is through
the rainbow road level from mario kart
meet thor the least relatable marvel
hero since dr strange he's an idiot
demigod prince with a magical hammer
that really needs to buy a vowel
[Music]
but thor isn't the only god in town
meet loki thor's evil stepbrother who
will stop at nothing to betray his
adopted father with the help of his real
father i will conceal you and you can
slay him where he lies in order to
betray his real father your death came
by the son of odin to impress his
adopted father i could have done it
father for you
that makes even less sense than his plan
from the avengers not a great plan
meet odin thor and loki's dad who pretty
much guarantees that one of his kids
will grow up to resent the other only
one of you can ascend to the throne
but both of you were born to be kings oh
and all these rejects from lord of the
rings game of thrones and xena warrior
princess
with the former god of thunder as he
stripped of his powers and banished to
these two square blocks in the new
mexico desert there he'll acclimate to
our strange earth customs like ordering
in restaurants
and horse purchasing i need a horse we
don't have horses just dogs and give me
one of those large enough to ride watch
as thor turns to jane foster for help a
brilliant astrophysicist with supermodel
good looks that just happens to be
single and who immediately falls in love
with thor for no good reason
make that six reasons
abs so ride along with thor as he loses
then regains his magic powers hooks up
with jane saves two different realms
from destruction and learns the virtues
of patience and humility all over the
course of a long weekend
seriously this whole movie takes place
over two and a half days starring
thunder from down under pokemon the
godfather idris elbow lord zett from
power rangers one bro girl and port
mandia
thor's obligatory movie
so loki dies at the end and comes back
to life by the end of the credits that's
gotta be some kind of record
[Music]
from the studio dumb enough to sell
their marvel franchise rights to disney
comes yet another movie that only exists
to set up the avengers captain america
the first avenger
stand tall for a superhero movie with an
important message it's what's on the
inside that counts except for when it
comes to fighting
or being respected look at that he's
making me cry or getting laid women
aren't exactly lying enough to dance
with the guy they might step on
meet johnny storm the human torch wait
no that's wrong movie meet steve rogers
a grown man's head cgi'd onto a little
boy's body he's a skinny kid from
brooklyn who dresses like it's the 1940s
so basically a modern-day kid from
brooklyn watch as he becomes a superhero
in the most american way possible
steroids how'd you feel
abs he'll juice up to become captain
america a soldier with the powers of
being a little bit stronger than a
regular strong guy ultimate frisbee and
uh super sobriety i can't get drunk
forget tony stark's ridiculous 3d
holograms and return to an analog world
full of lever pulling
[Music]
switch flipping
button pressing
[Music]
dial turning
[Applause]
and people calling out percentages with
absolutely no context that's 10
that's 50
that's 40
60 30 60 80 40. 90. that's 100
ride along with captain america as he
faces off against the evil red skull who
along with everyone else in sci-fi and
fantasy is played by hugo weaving cheer
as the captain defeats his legendary
arch-nemesis in a brisk two-minute
montage all to leave more time for
foreshadowing the avengers introducing
the plot device from the avengers
unnecessarily freezing himself so he can
be in the avengers and an after credit
scene that is literally a trailer for
the avengers
starring the 90 year old virgin tommy
lee groans one face two-face red-faced
ewface german capote dr strangelove the
winter spoiler agent love interest and
robert downey senior captain america the
first avengers trailer
raiders of the lost ark get it better
just saying
[Music]
from joss whedon god of the nerds comes
the movie blockbuster that finally
unites the world's greatest superheroes
that marvel still has the rights to
the avengers the ultimate two-hour geek
fantasy that blinds all nerds from
admitting any legitimate criticism and
put all of dc comics on suicide watch
a villain who inexplicably returns from
the dead will valve vengeance on the
planet where his demigod brother's sort
of girlfriend lives
forcing this bluetooth obsessed
government agency to assemble the heroes
from marvel's greatest franchises except
spider-man fantastic four and x-men suit
up with iron man everyone's favorite
secondary marvel character who must
redeem himself from the god-awful iron
man 2. thor who sort of pulled off his
own movie but whose appearance here
completely negates its ending captain
america
no one's favorite character who just
kinda has to be there and the incredible
hulk who for the sake of the plot can
now suddenly control his rage i'm always
in
without any explanation
which doesn't matter cause that shot was
awesome
witness the excitement
i need you to get to that pension
control panel of iron man repairing a
spaceship for 20 minutes
the thrill of generic aliens on flying
jet skis the confusing energy source of
the tesseract the tesseract can't fight
you can't protect against yourself and
it's completely unjustified fail safe
the explosion that instantly kills every
alien conveniently tying up all loose
ends the bromance
[Music]
and the character in the middle of the
credits who every nerd in the audience
pretended to know
a movie so fulfilling you won't remember
that the first 45 minutes are actually
kind of boring
a villain so determined you need the
cube to bring me home but i've sent it
off i know not where you'll wonder why
he's uniting the only people who can
stop him in hopes of getting them to
dislike each other
not a great plan
battles so action-packed
get a lot of space stuff in your tail
you won't even ask yourself how are they
even all talking to each other without
earpieces
can anybody copy
do it no wait
stark these things are still coming
started bore
pink eye iron man pooping not edward
norton the human torch
leather boobs mace windu and gay bane
marvel's the avengers if this doesn't
make your inner eight-year-old self
squeal and delight you're likely dead
inside or a girl
[Music]
when a terrorist mastermind kidnaps the
president and brings a country to its
knees there's only one marvel franchise
that disney can afford to call
i wish actually just this guy no really
just the guy not even the suit tony
stark is regular man in iron man 3
prepare for an iron man movie with
hardly any iron man in it and no ac dc
either
suit up with billionaire tony stark as
he doesn't suit up in a summer
blockbuster that for no reason at all
takes place on christmas and see him
like you've never wanted to see him
before insecure i'm a piping hot mess
anxious check the heart check to check
that is the brain and paralyzed with
fear
with regular man sidelined by the
whispers of children
it's up to his latest creation to save
the day remote control man this is a new
level of lane you've seen the iron man
armor hold its own against thor the god
of thunder now after dozens of upgrades
it runs out of batteries
malfunctions falls apart
falls apart again
whatever
and takes its sweet time to assemble
that
five four three come on
two
five
seriously the avengers assembled faster
than this but remote control man's not
alone tony spent his down time building
all kinds of robots that break faster
than bad cosplay like forearms man
choking hazard man and crane steadying
juggernaut man tony and his crappy suits
must pull together to face his greatest
foe since alcoholism
the mandarin you'll never see me coming
in a timely update of the character
osama bin kingsley plays the brilliant
terrorist who manipulates the entire
country into doing his bidding
my name's trevor travis lottery wait
what i'm an actor
mandarin see it's not real no you can't
do that
they were doing such a good job then
they turned him into a punch line this
is iron man's arch [ __ ] nemesis this
isn't just ignoring the comics this is
dropping their pants and wiping their
butt with them what bad guy did they
even replace him with i am the mandarin
oh come on
instead we get aldrich killian an
ex-nerd out for revenge after tony
skipped a meeting one time and his
nameless henchman with a confusing grab
bag of firepowers like glowing getting
hot exploding super strength regrowing
limbs flame proof clothes and shooting
fire out of their mouths
they really just made it up as they went
along huh
witness the least thought out sequence
of the iron man trilogy as tony stark
gives his personal address to a
terrorist 10 80 malibu point then goes
home and puts on his only unfinished
iron man suit let someone walk through
his front door doesn't see the missile
heading for his house until it's on the
news still doesn't activate any kind of
home security system or any of the 40
other remote-controlled iron man suits
in his basement or have jarvis call the
police or shield or an avenger
so you tell me nick fury shows up for
coffee and donuts but not when tony
stark might be dead
so watch as the iron man trilogy ends
with 10 of the franchise's most
disappointing minutes where killian
loses to gwyneth paltrow in yoga pants
all the iron man suits get blown up for
no reason and tony has the operation
that will make him regular man forever
at least until avengers 2
starring r2dj cooper hero
gandhi nerdy
murtaugh vincent vega and the worst
extra ever when is somebody going to
kill this guy
just saying and not starring the hulk
thor captain america nick fury black
widow hawkeye agent coulson agent maria
hill salve or even the gallagher guy
iron man 3
so you heard none of it i'm not that
kind of doctor dude where were you the
whole movie
[Music]
you've seen thor the film that tided
fans over until the avengers now
experience the film that will tide fans
over until the avengers 2
thor the dark world
thor is back in another perfectly
adequate marvel movie that pleasantly
killed a few hours of your time with
enough cool visuals action and humor to
keep you from wondering why does the elf
man want to shoot magic kool-aid into
the sky holes
return for another post avengers movie
full of references to the avengers
you're in new york
that was for new york but no actual
avengers
instead of earth's mightiest heroes
watch thor team up once again with
heimdall the watchful guardian who can
see everything
except for the spy
and thor's girlfriend
concealer and this gigantic spaceship
directly above him
the warriors three who are so
replaceable they switched out one of the
actors and you totally didn't notice and
everyone's favorite loki the charismatic
trickster who no one should trust by now
you still don't trust me brother would
you
no idiot when he's not battling yet
another forgettable bad guy watch as the
mighty thor mopes around asgard in the
snuggie because he's still hung up on a
girl he's been one long weekend with and
hasn't called in two years
where were you natalie portman returns
as jean grey from the x-men phoenix saga
with the help of her wacky sidekick her
other wacky sidekick and her other wacky
sidekick's wacky sidekick they'll
discover the convergence a piece of
science mumbo jumbo everyone keeps
trying to explain once a cycle all the
world's aligned the alignment is only
temporary he must be in exactly the
right place at the right time physics is
going to go ballistic increases and
decreases in gravity spatial extrusions
whatever can we just see thor hit
something with a hammer again
thank you travel across the nine realms
ranging from earth to vanaheim to svubs
fought off
sparta to asgard home of the most
penetrable impenetrable city ever
so ride along with the god of thunder we
are not gods
so ride along with the guy of thunder
for another celebration of the male form
in all its beauty featuring ass
tush and pixelated balls
starring gail's brother natalie
portwoman four loki goldeneye the nutty
professor an oscar ken jennings stanley
and mugatu
thor the dark world
now you're thinking with portals
[Music]
you weren't that impressed with his
first movie he wasn't your favorite
avenger
now
get ready for the sequel that made
everyone say
holy [ __ ]
who knew captain america kicked so much
ass
captain america the winter soldier
the captain is back and he didn't skip
leg day
thrill as he ditches his lame avenger
suit for a cool new one and shows off
the full range of his vaguely defined
superpowers like
super gymnastics super throwing
super catching
and super jumping out of stuff
[Music]
is he wearing a parachute
when he's not kicking ass or taking
names follow cab as he spends his free
time
freaking out kids at museums
hanging with his gift
and catching up on the last 60 years of
pop culture i'll put it on the list
man star wars must have blown his mind
when hydra returns cab needs to take him
out by forming a team he can trust
including black widow a sneaky double
agent who he really shouldn't trust and
falcon a random guy he met on the street
sam wilson steve rogers watch his cab
and two non-superheroes end up actually
taking a lot of ass together in a really
entertaining well-directed movie
what we have to be honest it's good but
since honest trailers is a comedy series
get ready for
nitpicking
prepare for the shocking revelation that
hydra has been secretly growing inside
of shield all along despite the fact
that the previous marvel movies really
didn't do anything to set that up and
get ready to try to ignore questions
like when did nick fury stop wearing the
bulletproof vest that saved his life in
the avengers why didn't tony stark find
out about hydra when he decrypted all of
shield's files in a few hours i'll know
every dirty secret shield has ever tried
to hide how did an agency that employs
thousands of people hide the fact that
half of its agents were members of a
secret nazi death cult for over 60 years
if shield had their hands on the
tesseract for so long why didn't hydra
just use that to take over the world
that was the red skull's plan in the
first place right and he was the og
hydra and if nick fury was such a threat
why didn't hyder try to kill him before
he saved tony stark's life thought out
their greatest enemy and assembled a
team of superheroes that would almost
certainly stop any evil plans they had
for the future
see we told you it'd be nitpicking
so sit back and enjoy the best
standalone marvel movie since iron man
full of awesome action awesome cameos
and one awesome twist they run into the
ground where bucky turns out to still be
alive and dr zola turns out to still be
alive and nick fury turns out to still
be alive and crossbone turns out to
okay no one ever really dies in this
movie
still great though
starring american austin powers
maddie moody unfrozen caveman soldier
lucy falcon punch robert red toyota
and hail hard drive captain america
he's cool now
so cap that's the safety of the free
world on two people not wanting to buy
gum
not a great plan
okay okay we got it keep your star pads
on
[Music]
without the rights to some of its most
popular titles and its biggest stars
contracts about to expire watch marvel
studios scrape the bottom of the barrel
for their obscure 70s comic book that
barely anyone read proving once and for
all will see anything if you slap
marvel's name in front of it guardians
of the galaxy
suit up for marvel's attempt at star
wars in a science fantasy adventure
about heroes you've never heard of star
who protecting a planet none of them
live on from an underdeveloped alien
villain whose problems you couldn't care
less about
we're really reaching here this was a
fun movie
journey across the galaxy to meet this
gang of lovable misfits there's captain
star-lord from america the human leader
from a different time and place like
captain america
gamora the black widow-ish leather-clad
female assassin like black widow drax
the guy with the killer abs who doesn't
understand our customs in a thor kind of
way groot a big hulking tree
get it and rocket the wisecracking tech
genius with a drinking problem like tony
stark what i'm trying to say is they're
the space avengers but i guess it's
technically not stealing if they're
ripping off themselves
watch the guardians race to find an
excuse for more avengers sequels by
chasing after the infinity stone an orb
of world conquering power that no one
bothers to guard and a gem so powerful
it can kill you just by touching it
unless you're this guy
or you can join hands to disperse its
power unless you're these guys or you
can just jam it into a hammer and use it
safely from there it's best not to think
about it too hard
you thought the avengers was nerdy you
ain't seen nothing yet between all the
action and comedy get ready for a whole
lot of space mumbo jumbo i will unfurl 1
000 years of cree justice on xendor
what's important now is we get the
ravager's army to help us save xandar so
we can give the stone to yondu and the
remnants of these systems were forged
into concentrated ingots
then if you can figure any of that out
try to figure out why this blue alien
isn't working with this blue alien who's
working for this blue alien to kill this
green alien who both want to kill this
purple alien as does this christmas
colored alien
but if you get confused just remember
the hero is still the white guy
so experience the swagger of a movie
studio trunk on its own power as marvel
trolls the world with balls out middle
fingers to the audience they know they
have in the palm of their hands oh you
like superheroes well how about a movie
that stars a [ __ ] raccoon in a
[ __ ] tree you like vin diesel yeah
well we cast him and he only says one
[ __ ] line
you want more pedigreed actors we'll put
him in stupid outfits and make them say
space [ __ ] all nova pilots
interlock and form a blockade because
who doesn't want to be in a [ __ ]
marvel movie
hey recognize that chubby idiot from
parks and rec we're gonna turn him into
a sex symbol that would be hilarious
remember the worst movie we ever made
howard the duck stick that after the
credits when everyone's expecting
avengers 2. it'll totally [ __ ] with our
fans and they'll love it anyways
speaking of which remember thanos from
that one scene at the end of the
avengers a few years ago well we're
bringing him back and he's still not
doing [ __ ]
why because [ __ ] you we're marvel that's
why what are you gonna do watch dc
[Applause]
thought so
starring
marvel chris number three
green natieri
draxon drax off chewbarka
the [ __ ]
blue man group dr steve rule and
darkseid
marvel space avengers
[Music]
okay i get where star-lord's walkman
came from but where do you get a tape
deck for a spaceship
galaxy shack
[Music]
after the mind-blowing success of the
avengers the game-changing thrills of
the winter soldier and the unexpected
surprise of guardians of the galaxy you
thought there was no way the next
avengers could live up to the hype you
were
right avengers age of ultron
i mean it's definitely good just not
great you know what i mean like
certainly enjoyable but you know oh man
we're gonna catch hell for this aren't
we
when the mandarin seemingly killed iron
man and took the president hostage the
avengers didn't assemble when malekith
almost destroyed the universe the
avengers didn't assemble and when a
terrorist organization infiltrated
shield and came just seconds away from
killing millions the avengers still
didn't assemble but when a remote hydra
base might be hiding something every
single avenger is assembling all up in
his business for even
more
group shots
hey does that mean we can finally stop
using this one joss whedon is back at
the helm and more beat down than ever in
the second one the job just got harder
oh i have all these restrictions but i
also have all these guidelines as he
does his best to meet our unrealistic
nerd expectations and tries to make a
standalone sequel as good as empire
strikes back or godfather 2 that also
sets up civil war every time someone
tries to win a war before it starts
innocent people die and sets up infinity
war the mind stone is the fourth of the
infinity stones to show up in the last
few years and sets up thor ragnarok we
are all dead
can you not see him and sets up black
panther
nada
wakanda and fits in disney corporate
cross promotions i have no strings so i
have fun in a juggling act so insanely
difficult he turned down the sequel quit
twitter and doesn't have any new films
in development
oh uh guys
i think we just broke joss whedon he
needs a hug experience the movie
equivalent of emptying out your entire
toy box and smashing all your action
figures into each other as the avengers
roster blows even further with vision
scarlet witch and quicksilver who for
some reason are never called vision
scarlet witch or quicksilver one is a
lame russian knockoff of the x-men that
fox did way better one has hand-wavy
mind control powers and can also stop
trains and the other is a beam-shooting
3d printed vibranium robot
plus jarvis plus the mind stone who can
fly and makes capes what can one of you
guys explain vision to me i have no idea
who or what he is you've seen great
marvel movie villains like loki and
no no
no
definitely not not even close huh guess
it's still just loki now get ready for
another generically evil one-off villain
who hates the avengers 4 reasons with an
overcomplicated plot to evolve and or
destroy the world by turning an eastern
european city into a meteor not a great
plan
you've been waiting for years to see
your heroes come together again now
watch them fight for limited screen time
full of rushed side plots like black
widow's black swan school
thor's magic jacuzzi if the water
spirits accept me i can return to my
dream captain america's old party thing
and the most out of left-field love
story since spock and uhura but don't
worry there's still plenty of time left
over for your least favorite avenger to
become your third or fourth least
favorite avenger oh hawkeye good for you
we like you now
get ready for everything you loved about
the first avengers movie all over again
mind control
again
looking for loki scepter again a thanos
tease again a final showdown against a
faceless army with a ticking clock again
and tons of
crips well i'm decrypting nuclear codes
and you don't want me to use guys
multiplying faster than a catholic
rabbit we won't hold it against you if
you can't get it up andy did a bank seat
at the crime scene with the benefit of
hindsight stop quipping it's good talk
no it wasn't i didn't say you could
leave you're all not worthy language you
son of a [ __ ] you kiss your mother with
that mouth then banner better not be
plain hide the zucchini really you've
never made an omelet you beat me by one
second oh man these things are going to
be insufferable when ant-man and
star-lord show up
starring
mr rogers hank pym
beats by bruce good luck finding her
action figure archer
farm and furious so that's what andy
circus looks like resting witchface the
quick and the dead
cgi bombs
super siri
skynet
and the new avengers yay
avengers roughly one week of ultron
i'm calling it the shield helicarrier
will become the mcu's
eagles are coming
[Music]
from edgar wright until he refused to
get in line comes a movie based on a
superhero so ridiculous you'll swear
marvel's choosing their projects on a
dare
ant-man
you've seen marvel movies based on green
giants norse gods and these weirdos now
get ready for a hero so silly no one can
even keep a straight face when they say
his dumb name
ant-man and man
is it too late to change the name in
this super-powered heist film that
against all odds actually kind of works
i mean it's still more believable than
letting someone join the avengers just
because they're good with a bow and
arrow right
meet scott lang say yes scott
wait nope not that one yeah that's the
guy a master thief who gets busted every
time he tries to get away with anything
hey little guy
his life will change when he meets hank
pym the billionaire industrialist who
lost control of his company to a bald
former ally who betrays him and plots to
use his advanced suit technology for
evil and if that sounds familiar it's
because it's the exact same premise as
the first iron man movie if it ain't
broke i mean seriously it even has that
friend staring at the suit though
wearing the sequel moment next time baby
it's about damn time
thrill at amazing visual effects that
makes 70 year old michael douglas look
like 60 year old michael douglas and has
harmless locations pulsed with epic
danger like a briefcase a toy train set
and michael pena's junk
in some of the most high high-stakes
fights between tiny people since frodo
vs gollum proving marvel still hasn't
run out of ways for guys to punch each
other in the face or in this movie's
case sucker punch and now it's gonna
blow up in your face
that's how you punch prepare for a movie
that would be really stale without paul
rudd doing paul rudd things because most
of it is hank pym yammering on about
some boring science crap i use
electromagnetic waves to stimulate their
olfactory nerve center you must retrieve
this prototype of a signal decoy i
created a formula that altered atomic
relative distance huh she turned off her
regulator
he went subatomic but separates itself
from the other 11 mcu movies with a few
unique twists like making another
schlubby comedian get abs for a
superhero role actually getting you to
care about disgusting insect monsters
no
not anthony oh man i like that one
because he had a name and saying the one
thing everyone's been yelling at the
screen since phase two started i think
our first move
should be calling the avengers
so strap in for the best micro movie
since honey i shrunk the kids as marvel
proves once again they can literally
sell you anything and they don't even
have to try that hard to sell it
ants
huh story
i love you mant
tony stark senior
wasp machine
the only latino in the mcu
ti as himself
as the biggest avenger they could get
thomas and the mantjic railroad and
disposable marvel villain number nine
tiny iron man
man after this one i cannot imagine
these movies getting any strange oh yeah
forgot about that
[Music]
you've seen them fight as hero versus
hero you've seen them fight as friend
versus friend now the greatest threat to
the avengers is it's gonna be themselves
again isn't it yep that's what happens
when your villains kind of suck captain
america
civil war
loosely based on the comic book
crossover event comes the epic struggle
that has your favorite heroes asking is
it better to be dickishly stubborn if i
see a situation pointed south i can't
ignore it or stubbornly dickish
sometimes i want to punch you in your
perfect teeth in a film that settles a
moral and political debate the only way
superheroes know how by beating the crap
out of each other
take that regulatory oversight
the government wants to rein in the
avengers for when they recklessly save
the entire world from aliens that other
time when they save the entire world
from a secret nazi death cult and again
save the entire world from the army of
murder robots they created okay that one
is on them ultron
now captain america must get in line or
face the prospect of an all-out civil
war or at least one group sparring
session you're pulling your punches one
real fight and a nice letter reminding
us that everything is still hunky-dory
tony if you need me i'll be there what
you thought there'd be lasting stakes
come on this is marvel we're talking
about
cap is back and he's still a total
beefcake leading a team of rebels
alongside his quippy black best friend
because you're gonna have to go mark
furman on my ass hawkeye who's great in
small doses and man who's there scarlet
witch who's still doing vague hand wavy
stuff and bucky the man whose haircut
was frozen in the 90s
opposing them is team iron man his
quippy black best friend yes this is
this is tony stank black widow who's
still scissoring anyone she can get her
legs around
black panther the king of giving
monologues into the middle distance dead
it's not the end
a mantel passed from warrior to warrior
if i can help one of them find peace
whatever the hell vision is do you know
i don't know what this is yeah neither
do we buddy and the best version of
spider-man complete with a pre-murdered
uncle ben hey um i'm peter tony if tony
gives him the great power great
responsibility speech i am so out of
here
thrill as these former friends become
enemies thanks to the evil zemo a man
out for revenge by framing the winter
soldier for the murder of king to chaka
which will uh
hold on i forgot can we roll zemo's plan
again
[Music]
uh-huh yeah
rex's car really
stealing a book
okay
not sure he drowned in that sink though
okay that makes sense
there's no way he knew those guys were
gonna show up
wait so he called the mate from russia
ah the old captured on purpose boy
someone's been reading loki's plan oh
this is dumber than luther's not a great
plan uh can we just play the airport
scene again
oh that's so cool he was like the size
of an ant now he's a giant
experience a film that's more than just
mindless action it's also about love
watch tony stark deal with a heartbreak
of dating someone whose contract expired
after iron man 3. we're taking a break
the weird flirtation of this weird
british christmas robot and this weird
witch who puts him in the front hole
and the greatest love story of all as
steve rogers once again pines for the
plums of the man that only he and tumblr
really care about as he tries to redeem
this brainwashed killer caveman for the
second movie in a row i don't know if
i'm worth all this steve while ignoring
two perfectly good boyfriends who are
right there in front of his face we need
you kim and now he has to go in the run
before he can seal the deal with peggy
carter's niece
90 years old and this guy is still a
virgin someone please have sex with
captain america already hell you know
what i'll do it i'll bend over right now
so go enjoy the hero vs hero movie that
everyone loved instead of the hero vs
hero movie that most everyone hated even
though they're a lot more similar than
anyone would like to admit
featuring a non-superpowered villain
tricking a symbol of america into
fighting a billionaire playboy using an
incoherent plan that includes blowing up
a meeting of government officials and
using the hero's moms to manipulate them
save
martha
i don't care
he killed my mom that ends with an
ominous warning from a prison cell and
sets up a universe worth of spin-offs
along the way
oh
cue the airport scene again oh come on
ah that's better
starring barnes and noble robert downey
jr junior man lisandra awesomeo
jeremy againer put a bird on it walkie
road the spectacular sony man
tahala
womb raider another blue marvel villain
you know cause he said brian fantanta
and giant location
headers vienna
queens 1991 cleveland wait there's no
reason to get that excited about
cleveland captain america three avengers
2.5 boy that escalated quickly
that's you right
so how did tony know that peter parker
was spider-man would he just break into
every teenage boy's bedroom in new york
until he got lucky oh wait hang on that
sounded really bad
[Music]
after ant-man asked the question you
ever watch iron man but small marvel's
latest solo movie invites you to ask
another
you ever watch iron man on weed
doctor strange
experience the grand illusion that you
haven't seen this movie before as you
sit through the heroic origins of a
cocky but capable super rich
wisecracking workaholic with a weird
goatee in love with a redheaded
subordinate learning to be less selfish
played by a famous sherlock holmes actor
it's like iron man but actually that's
it it's pretty much just like iron man
magic has come to the marvel universe
and not that it's just science bs that
thor went on about your ancestors called
it magic and you call it science we're
talking acid trip 70s black light poster
magic that bends space and time and new
plot-breaking ways and uses mind-blowing
effects to distract you from the fact
that the action is still 90 punchy
um shouldn't that hurt his hands
you cringed when he tried to do a
southern accent power didn't go out i i
forgot to set the clock i'm sorry mom
you weren't sure if he was serious when
he attempted a boston one you know what
john good to see you doing so well now
benedict cumberbatch will sound like an
english man pretending to be a german
man pretending to be an american in a
feature-length tribute to hans gruber
accent and die hard when he gets caught
by bruce willis please god no you're one
of them you care
so much don't you benny bobby your
natural voice is perfect use it
joining the titular strange on his
journey from act one protagonist to act
three protagonists are side characters
and villains who are up to the usual
marvel standard chihuatel engie four
who's just kind of there to explain
things temporal manipulations can create
branches in time this is a relic the
sanctums protect the world and we
sorcerers protect the sanctums
that's mickelson playing a bad guy with
weird eyes for the third time in his
career whose entire plan revolves around
successfully ripping some pages out of a
book to summon a malevolent demon who he
hoax won't enslave the human race not a
great plan
tilda swinton a being of immense power
bravely guarding the marvel cinematic
universe from asian actors she's celtic
and this cloak with more personality
than any of the human beings
[Applause]
stop man i want to see that cloak
crossover with the rug and aladdin so
bad
enjoy a visual masterpiece that has to
be seen in 3d on a giant screen to be
fully appreciated because when you watch
it on a laptop you realize just how much
of it is medical mumbo jumbo we need to
get a prep for suboccipital craniotomy
i'm fusing transected spinal cords i'm
stimulating neurogenesis in the central
nervous system pass a stent down the
brachial artery under the radial artery
it's a complete c7 c8 spinal cord injury
with a heaping side order of magic mumbo
jumbo the dark dimension makes them more
powerful in the mirror dimension saw the
rituals in the book of kagliosa i pushed
your astral form out of your physical
form the wand of a tomb the vaulting
boots of valtor phases of case of their
stall a ritual to contact the mamu and
draw power from the dark dimension when
guardium levios suck me sideways this is
unnecessary just shoot laser beams out
of your wand and be done with it
so enjoy a film that despite its faults
doesn't fall into the third act trap of
battling a cgi army into sky beam saves
money by replaying the same scene 13
times in a row
and sends a powerful message to the
children modern medicine can't be
trusted my spirit deepened and somehow
your body healed yes and don't text and
dry because you might end up turning
into a wizard
starring
benedict wong
benedict white
bordeaux
morpheus you mads bro
night nurse
circle hands
hands on hands on hands on hands on
hands on hands and ricky bobby hands
[Music]
i'm not sure what to do with my hands
stranger things
so cumberbatch did the motion capture
for dormammu himself man he really likes
to goof around leotards huh none
can stop me
[Music]
from marvel and james gunn the director
and studio who surprised everyone with
guardians of the galaxy comes a cool
looking super fun laugh out loud but
ultimately kind of forgettable sequel
what it's still better than all the
other marvel part 2s except for winter
soldier is that better
guardians of the galaxy vol 2
[Music]
blast off again with marvel's space
avengers a team of misfits who learned
how to work together in their first
movie then turned back into aho so they
can learn it all over again like a
professional ass little one in this
playful action comedy where the heroes
never really get hurt
the danger never really feels that
imminent
and the jokes definitely don't fall flat
but let's be honest they aren't as funny
as the characters think they are
[Laughter]
okay guys
it's it's funny you know
scale it back a little
[Laughter]
hey let me decide when to laugh all
right
just shut up
catch up with all your favorite heroes
like star-lord who discovers he's the
son of a god and a [ __ ] well i don't
know what you're talking about but i
like the way you say it gamora who
ditches the strong silent badass trope
to become a strong silent badass with
the more interesting sister an ad for
baby groot toys
rocket whose eyes don't work apparently
damn it i'm using my left eye i'm using
my wrong eye again aren't i if it's how
eyesight works you stupid raccoon did i
miss something newcomer mantis with the
power of getting roasted by everyone you
are horrifying to look at i never
thought she'd be able to do it with as
weak and skinny as she appears to be oh
i'm imagining being with you physically
including herself i'm certainly grateful
to be ugly
and drax the once tragic warrior who's
become an aggressively dumb sex freak
did you make a penis i like a woman with
some meat on her bones my father would
tell the story of impregnating my mother
i have sensitive nibbles it would make
my nether regions and gorgeous okay look
you have a good thing going with drax
don't take it too far and urkel your
best character
prepare for an episode of my two dads in
space in a film that's so high on
friends being your real family you'll
swear you're watching a fast and furious
movie i finally found my family i
thought you already had you are not
friends you're right we're family i
don't have friends
i got family space dad one is ego the
living planet of exposition i call it
the expansion it is my purpose
now it is yours as he proves
everything's better with kurt russell
making ego the living planet grounded
and relatable until he goes full marvel
villain and becomes a blue alien made of
sky beams who wants to rule the universe
while space dad 2 proves that everything
is better with michael rooker as yondu
is retconned into a good guy who just
wanted to be a good pappy all to create
maximum emotional impact when he's
killed off in the most tragic marvel
death since uh
no
she was in her 90s so he came back he
came back he came back
he came back twice he came back on tv
quicksilver
wow i guess it's yondu by default i'm
very popping y'all
so get ready for a great time at the
theater as they bring back everything
you loved about the first movie the
music the slo-mo walks and the insane
visuals to the things you didn't think
could come back like the laughing at the
dumb name bit star-lord who your name is
it's taserface rocket having someone
steal a fake body part for him i was
just kidding about the leg what no i
thought i thought it'd be funny was it
buddy he's not gonna know
where his eye is and undercutting most
of the serious dramatic moments with
jokes even the emotional climax of the
film i tried
so hard
to find the form that best suited you
it's okay marvel we've been following
these movies for 10 years now you can
let us go without a chuckle for 10
minutes finally get to be the
father i've always wanted to be excuse
me gotta take a whiz
maybe not
starring
arthur meme
han brolo
grina warrior princess
big blue beetle borg drak shepard
i emerge star fox do a barrel roll
whistle while you murk
mantis toboggan
ego the [ __ ] planet
and ready player one
dead rock the movie
it's called a zune it's what everybody's
listening to on earth nowadays oh the
zune is from the early 2000's i don't
think starla is going to be happy when
he finds out what happened to rock and
roll
[Music]
since 2002 we've had six movies two
reboots and three spider-man now just
when audiences might be getting a little
sick of the franchise marvel swoops in
to deliver a crowd-pleasing comedy
that's going to keep spider-man in
theaters until the freaking sun burns
out of the sky
spider-man homecoming
toby maguire couldn't keep it up andrew
garfield couldn't get it started but tom
holland hits the ground swinging
in a great reboot that just assumes
you're all caught up in the mcu pretty
sure this guy's a war criminal now but
whatever complete with a glossed over
origin story an actor who doesn't have
premature old face and a villain who
doesn't already have some forced
personal connection to peter park unless
he's dead
all right two out of three ain't bad
witness a brand new take on spider-man
he's a millennial now who can't stay off
his phone
what is the current standard unit i'll
take this real quick i'll only be
exactly fine
constantly vlogs watches himself on
youtube and has zero patience for
anything hey how long we've been here
anyways 37 minutes what he's got all the
usual spider skills plus a powerful new
one
never facing consequences for his
actions whether he's getting away with
ditching detention hey where you going
get back here quitting on his team you
can't just quit on a stroll up and be
welcome back hey welcome back peter
falsely imprisoning people
shouldn't steal cars is bad it's my car
dumb ass wrecking a car
wrecking a store
wrecking a ferry or wrecking his
girlfriend's entire life whatever's
going on with you i hope you figure it
out you can be sure this web slinger
will get off with no more than a stern
talking to you're a good kid and you're
a smart kid so just try to keep your
head straight okay all right all right
get out of here well the older i get the
more i relate to j jones and jameson
he's a menace to the entire city
i want that wall crawling erected
prosecuted
you've seen him as batman and birdman
now prepare for michael keaton's third
wing creature role as the vulture he's a
blue-collar guy who gets shafted by
stark industries
and instead of filing a lawsuit against
a billionaire clearly in the wrong he'll
build a giant bird mech jet pack
you'll be bored stiff when vulture
fights spider-man in bland cgi slug
fests but genuinely scared when he's
just being michael keaton were you
scared
i bet you're glad when your old pal
spider-man showed up in the elevator
though
sorry uncle ben and richard parker
there's a new absentee dad in town tony
stark iron man is back as the drunk rich
stepfather you'd expect him to be who'll
build you a killer robot suit activating
instant kill send you into battle at 15
then literally phone in his parenting
until you screw up enough to get his
attention okay it's not working out i'm
going to need the suit back really tony
you just bought your best friend over
keeping tabs on superheroes and you just
let your pet superhero run amok is
anyone paying attention to the timeline
anymore this is approaching x-men levels
of sloppy so she sends bishop back in
time now just his consciousness into his
younger self
wow
so enjoy another super smash hit whose
success was far from guaranteed with two
competing studios fighting for control
six different screenwriters and a
director with just two low-budget indies
to his name dang it's like sony finally
cracked the code on how to make the
spider-verse happen let marvel do the
work
starring
tom netherlands
drunkel stark only winners do drugs
chef the disembodied voice of jennifer
connolly you can call me karen if you
would like marissa tomei
vulture or the unexpected virtue of
casting michael keaton
technically in the movie tony ravioli
mary pixie jane girl hey there martin
star now not not your asian sidekick and
wonder woman
the perks of being a wall crawler
bold move putting a set piece in an
elevator shaft spider-man can't catch a
break with that
[Music]
from marvel studios
the new logo is still going all right
i'll wait
[Music]
from
still going
[Music]
all right here it comes
from
[Music]
jeez how long is this thing just cut it
off nobody has time for that great now
we're running behind it's thor thor
ragnarok
after the dark world marvel is back with
a radical new formula for the thor films
not making them suck yes
in an installment that trims all the
dead weight off the franchise from his
love interest sorry to hear that jane
dumps you to his homeland to his friends
you could name with a gun to your head
to his right eye to his dad his hair
dang even his hammer
they just trimmed all the weight off huh
it's like the whole franchise got on
hemsworth's steamed chicken diet
meet thor god of thunder who despite
being able to shoot lightning from his
hands spends most of the film getting
electrocuted
when thor's father luke skywalkers
himself into the afterlife his sister
hella goddess of pointy things will
return to claim the throne in an epic
family feud that will make you wonder
are we sure thor wasn't the adopted one
put him next to hello loki and young
anthony hopkins and tell me he's not the
odd got out
the real as indie comedy director taika
waititi takes the reigns of a giant
superhero movie because when you're part
of a 14 billion global franchise ytf not
now it's out with the old and in with
the jokes behold
my stuff where boring exposition scenes
get tagged by jokes i will tower over
the mountains and bury my sword deep in
asgard hang on give it a second badass
moments get tagged by jokes you wanted
to know who i am
[Music]
and even heartfelt emotional beats get
tagged by jokes piss off ghosts
yeah they overdo it sometimes but this
is a movie where an orgy spaceship
shoots fireworks over the rainbow bridge
where hulk fights a zombie wolf if
you're mad at tries to make you laugh
too you're doing it wrong
follow thor's exile on sakaar a
collection of the galaxy's most colorful
gladiators garbage and gold blues
he's going to get him first
and thrill as it turns into the closest
thing we'll get to a planet hulk movie
where bruce banner awakens to find he
spent the last two years of his life as
an enslaved killing machine i've been
hulk for two years what the hell
happened and take all of nine minutes to
get over it you want revenge um and i'm
just undecided together they'll team up
with new additions to the thorny verse
like the depressive alcoholic valkyrie
drinks a taika waititi made of rocks
crucible
and a mute bug with knives for arms and
they still have more personality than
the warriors three dodge that bullet
lady sif but don't worry you still got
it coming
enjoy the first marvel film where
everything actually looks like a classic
marvel comic book that reminds us all
thor is a cosmic viking created by nerds
on acid in the 60s it should look crazy
with the best bridge sequence since
deadpool the best two man laser fights
in starship troopers and the best
vehicle chase sequence where the hero
jumps out to take the bad guys down by
hand since all the other ones
[Music]
hey we found marvel's new sky beam
yay
so get pumped for what's easily the best
thor movie also the best hulk movie
probably the best doctor strange movie
the second best guardians movie and
shoot probably the best he-man movie
we're ever gonna get to that hopefully
talked marvel an important lesson don't
fire the weirdo embrace him embrace that
weirdo
starring
happy thor dot gif i am lord yaya ya
actual jeff goldblum
for the horde
ben tim
someone get this woman an untitled
standalone movie timed all the time they
were able to get idris l before she's so
thorny
george r.r martin sure contractually
locked into a cameo
sorak the current state of the dc eu
could it be
satan and thor the 4d experience coming
summer 2020 to disney's california
adventure
flash thorden
look at these lies
[Music]
note to self before commissioning a
propaganda mural depicting my peaceful
rise to power don't commission another
mural depicting the horrible horrible
truth
[Music]
after 17 movies the mcu finally went
black putting out a black crude black
cast superhero movie that's one of the
best ever released leaving its haters
with only one option
watching every other mcu movie ever made
black panther
just when you thought chadwick boseman
had called dibs on every black icon he's
suiting up as black panther a superhero
with a high-tech suit of iron man the
all-natural steroids of captain america
and the invisible jet of wonder woman
but one thing sets him apart from all
the other mcu heroes not cause he's
black not cause he's royalty
nope it's cause this marvel hero
just
won't
quit
people are shooting at me wait let me
put on my helmet enough
you froze
we will not
help you
did he freeze like an antelope in
headlines
are you finished well his dad just died
and he didn't even crack a joke i
thought you had to be a smart ass to
save the world dance off bro
journey to wakanda a combination of the
jetsons and a 1990s jet magazine it's
the source of all the world's vibranium
a material so powerful it tops tony
stark's tech and doctor strange's magic
as the bs that can do whatever the
script needs it to do there's vibranium
on those trains it's vibranium all
around us that's how i healed you this
secret kingdom has been hidden for
centuries thanks to an ironclad policy
of asking people not to say anything you
speak nothing of these days but after
sitting out the slave trade brutal
dictators two world wars multiple alien
invasions and a sentient ai using stolen
vibranium to destroy the earth they're
finally ready to get involved in bay
area real estate i bought this building
and that's a prediction
and that one over there kidding steps
you guys
after taking 18 movies to get six
quality villains cry as marvel takes
just three movies to cut it back to two
maybe one
but for one shining moment we had claw
andy circus's joyous betrayal of a guy
who doesn't have to wear a mocap suit
but that was awesome that was awesome
and killmonger michael b jordan's
michael jordan of marvel villains hey
auntie he's the buffest dude to ever
graduate from mit who's ribbed for your
pleasure and who actually wins the moral
argument and changes the hero's mind
where was wakanda
all of you are wrong
to turn your backs on the rest of the
world so wait killmonger was right i am
not used to this much nuance in my
marvel villains quick make him choke an
old lady so i know who to root for
oh there he is
while the boys are at play it's the
women of black panther who do all the
work
like okoye literal snatcher of wigs
shuri expert in weaponized memes what
are those
angela bassett as herself and nakia who
after all the debate between t'challa
and killmonger was making the same case
all along and never got the credit for
it wakanda is strong enough to help
others and protect ourselves at the same
time also she saved the royal family
let's go also she saved the future of
the black panther wow i am not used to
this much agency in my marvel of
interest quick have her get rescued so i
know who the heroes are
so enjoy this movie with great acting i
must write these wrongs a great story
great things and great cultural
significance that almost lets you forget
the underdeveloped love stories would
you kill me in my life the terrible cgi
or the big forgettable third act
brouhaha
in other words it's a marvel movie
starring
the superhero formerly known as prince
oh there's wallace lupita you're so fine
you're so funny blow my mind lupita
lupita
fear the shaving head bilbo watson
token token white guy's joke the best
disney princess
war dog way of the samurai
buster bluth got out i bless the trains
down in africa
and the arsenio hall show
the aristocat
you know his heart's in the right place
but maybe don't let everett ross keep
any guys with one arm in custody guys
over too
[Music]
from the thanos of hollywood comes what
could be the best movie marvel's ever
made but without a doubt is the most
movie marvel's ever made
man there is just so much movie in this
movie
look at all that movie
avengers infinity war
journey into a new era of the mcu where
after 10 years of having to streamline
their plots so normies would know what's
happening marvel's gotten so big they'll
drop you right into episode 19 part one
of two without wasting a second on who
anyone is or why you should care because
let's face it you're either on this hype
train by now or the winter soldier using
rocket raccoon as a sidearm won't mean
to you don't you see they're both
cyborgs rebelling against their
destructive programming
dad why aren't you listening to me are
you yawning
all your favorite heroes are here like
tony stark the scientist who finds out
magic exists and takes it in stride he
came here to steal a necklace from a
wizard but literally can't even when
another quippy guy with a goatee shows
up what is your job exactly besides
making balloon animals star lord whose
entire first movie was completely undone
we'd like to express our profound
gratitude for your help in saving xandar
he decimated zanda and takes it in
stride but literally can't even when
another buff guy with blonde hair shows
up you mocking me he's trying to copy
captain america who heroically accepts
his reduced role as guy who knows a guy
can we do that not me not here i know
somewhere who could find vision then
probably steve rogers black panther
whose lack of screen time proves no one
knew how big of a deal he'd be
and spider-man the boy who'd rather hit
you right into space and die then stay
home and be in venom
you me both kid
but they're not alone because all these
other characters are also back like
bruce banner a man in desperate need of
a phase 3 recap video tony you've lost
another superbot who's scott ant-man
there's an ant-man and a spider-man
avengers broke up or toast like a band
like like the beatles scarlet witch the
x-man who's completed her halle berry
arc of losing her weird accent as the
movies go on everybody is afraid of
something well there are people who are
expecting me too you know we both made
promises gamora
the emotional center of the whole story
and the best actor
didn't see that one coming loki slightly
more dead than the last two times the
rest of the guardians pre-james gun
petition ah those were simpler times a
few weeks ago
and bucky the one-armed artisanal goat
cheese farmer but they're not alone
either because holy crap there are so so
many people in this movie
like rhodey okoye mantis vision falcon
wong shuri mbaku red skull nick fury oh
hey where you been thunderbolt ross
again
okay marissa hall right is that her name
pepper hey last phase one girlfriend
standing good for you
nit nedry and hawkeye's name where's
clint wow the only heroes missing are
the ones on all those netflix shows
kevin feige hates next time iron fist
next time
or not for all the characters crammed
into this thing thrill as it centers
around a buff bald guy trying to grow
his rock collection they're minerals
jesus
no thanos he's been looking for the
infinity stone so long he's changed
color twice and after he vowed in age of
ultron to do it himself i'm doing it
myself he waited like seven whole movies
including two that took place in space
and then boldly sent more of his kids to
do it for him you sir are a really bad
stepfather but dang what a great daddy
oh yeah
watch these movies catch up to one of
comics longest running traditions
briefly killing people off to goose
sails where with a single snap of the
fingers disney erased the box office
potential of black panther spider-man
five sevens of the guardians doctor
strange the winter soldier and one third
of the avengers and if you think these
deaths are gonna stick for longer than a
movie i've got a copy of the death of
superman to sell you i mean it's still
in the original bag mean condition with
the armband too come on no one how about
the death of tony stark dead the captain
america how about thor nick fury hawkeye
okay how about a copy of infinity
gauntlet where the same thing happens
and they all come back just fine cool
cool so cool starring
who throws a moon honestly
four stooges
beards of no nation he was a one-eyed
blonde thor flying purple people beater
under armour dumbo
portal combat
too long thanks for nothing signed the
avengers
shorty laforge a hologram for the king
teen titan blow
it wasn't me it was the one-armed stan
doo-doo-doo-doo-doo
red dead redemption
and
the dustus league
welcome
game of stones
so we're just gonna give him a pass for
pretending this was a standalone movie
yeah yeah we
[Music]
are as the mcu reaches its darkest hour
killing half of your favorite heroes in
an instant marvel's next movie will
answer the least important question on
everyone's minds
where
was paul
rudd
ant-man in the wasp
return to the franchise that everyone
likes but no one really cares about in
this satisfying episode of marvel season
three episode eight and while you don't
need to see the first ant-man to know
what's going on you definitely need to
catch up on captain america civil war
especially if you're in the movie i
really screwed up because they didn't
tell me when we started this but i
should go see captain america so when i
read the script for this i had no idea
the beginning what was going on you are
everyone's dad right now mr douglas and
i love you for it
the cutest marvel white boy not named
chris returns as ant-man the hero who
toes the line between effortless charm
and just plain effortless he'll team up
once again with hank pym the guy who
invented an end to world hunger then
used it to build fighting suits pope van
dyne the first female marvel hero in a
movie title and like the fifth female
marvel hero playing the series when
rolling her eyes at a goofy male
counterpart
and louise who makes up for being the
mcu movie's only mexican character by
being the absolute most mexican
character oh my lisa had a box in a
restaurant yeah only played morrissey
embark on a feature-length game of
capture the lab i've arranged some
buyers for your lab you got the lab got
to get that lab back we need to regroup
and figure out where the lab is tim's
lab is gone get my lab i want that lab
i'll get the lab cloud birch got the lab
i got the lab
[Music]
as our heroes race to save michelle
pfeiffer from 30 years in the quantum
realm a cgi wonderland made of doctor
strange outtakes easter eggs and i guess
beauty supplies because she came out of
there looking nice but hot on their
tails is ghost a girl who just wants to
cure her chronic pain
and gets the snot beaten out of her for
trying
that'll teach you not to want pain and
last but definitely least sunny burj a
regular guy with a couple of goons a tan
suit and a crappy restaurant i guess
i've also committed numerous health code
violations in my restaurant come on
where's his tech super moss he's going
after four of the strongest smartest
people in the mcu with nothing but a
cell phone and a dream oh come on iron
fist could beat this guy
iron fist
enjoy all the visual and memory you've
come to expect where little things are
in big end and big things are constantly
belittled if you two are finished
comparing sizes creating awesome action
scenes that spin in the face of physics
but according to marvel you can make
science do anything if you just slap the
word quantum on it quantum realm quantum
technology quantum anomaly quantum phase
quantum spectrometer and quantum system
quantum energy quantum research quantum
void quantum entanglement between the
quantum states quantum healing particles
you guys just put the word quantum in
front of everything hey stop calling out
your own lazy explanations that's our
job
so enjoy a film that managed to be funny
and compelling with good action and
great effects
that would have blown everyone's mind
less than 10 years ago this is awesome
but because it doesn't further marvel's
19 movie super pot enough nerds will
treat it like a pesky insect
um how many planets do they visit just
one a pass i don't get out of bed for
anything less than a celestial a good
day sir
starring
big hero shtix smalling down
if you like it then you should have put
a thing on it dumb zemo definitely not
nick fury i'm not lawrence pittsburgh
office park
a bug's wife
uh phasing
anthony mackey
and kevin and the feiges
west coast avengers
uh i hope all the furniture was bolted
down before you did that also i hope you
have a septic tank because those toilets
are not hooked up to anything
[Music]
from mark oh it's all stan lee cameos
that's not fair
you're gonna make me cry we haven't even
started yet
marvel is taking it back to the first
avenger
no not that one this avenger before all
the new ones like ant-man well not that
ant-man before black panther at least
well after t'chaka was black panther but
before t'challa right uh look i don't
know it's it's the 90s okay she's the
90s one
captain marvel
journey to holla
and meet captain marvel a girl with the
power of spaceship
she's a snarky flying soldier with
amnesia on a quest to recover her true
identity a snarky flying soldier without
amnesia just don't tell her how to feel
i'm too emotional there's nothing more
dangerous to a warrior an emotion you
struggle with your emotions do not let
your emotions override your judgment can
you keep your emotions in check long
enough to take me on because this
hotshot pilot likes to keep it in
neutral we'll get to the bottom of these
fears
together
okay
you okay
dreams again
carol calm down you're getting too
emotional okay
breathe the cree is not alone like every
marvel hero she needs someone to smirk
at like yon rogg her problematic yoda
maria rambo her marvel issued black
friend annette benning in a dual role as
a scientist we don't really get to know
and a computer we don't really
understand the dog from the thing in cat
form
and stealing the show a facially de-aged
nick fury an effect that will completely
fool the eye until you notice him run
fight
or use a keyboard
uh-oh grandpa's in the computer building
superhero teams again
you've waited years for marvel to
introduce the scrawls
thrill with the possibility that they'll
be the next big bad after thanos because
they could be anyone from captain
america to cute cuddly family men wait
the squirrels are nice how do you not
make ben mendelsohn evil ben mendelsohn
is always evil we are so not getting
secret invasion
are you ready for a blockbuster it won't
take alta vista to find one because
captain marvel is a street fighter too
and she's onto your game boy so back off
trolls and go back to the mall rats her
powers don't need to be nerfed cause
she's not melancholy about rocking the
vote in the bush leonard cohen holy sh
nikes these 90s references or his forces
the movies nine inch nails radio shack
all right i'm done
so get ready for a film that's
disappointing if it's the meat in an
infinity war sandwich a solid watch if
it's up against the other marvel origin
stories and citizen king k compared to
female ed superhero movies not named
wonder woman look out boys at this rate
lady heroes will take over at the
theater
never
starring
the captain is miss marvel nick fury
scroll and clones
law in orbit ask for you
blue man troop the garfield your aunt
still has stuck on her car windshield
maria rembolcott
skynet benning
ekrafria ethniage
who
paid dlc
and the screenwriter of what lies
beneath just a fun fact i know instead
of my daughter's birthday
last time i trusted someone i lost an
eye i'm trusting you not to eat me yeah
i don't know that's a stretch
[Music]
after 21 mcu movies prepare for the
final conclusion of the infinity saga
and also part two of infinity war
penultimate film of phase three intro to
phase four and backdoor pilot for about
three disney plush shows whew you
remember when movies just you know ended
and then your imagination had to take
over ugh sounds exhausting
avengers end game
the most successful crowd-pleasing
global film franchise is back but since
life on earth sucks now it's all about
grief
lost the kid guilt it's supposed to be
me depression are you crying
no
and despair then i should have killed
all of us because today's escapist
fantasy isn't becoming a superhero it's
going back to fix your mistakes instead
of scraping by in the waking nightmare
of your own failure
can i do a time heist on my life
five years have passed since half the
population vanished or as introverts
call it winning the lottery
ah
that looks nice baseball remains
unpopular culture got frozen in 2017.
damn and an actor shortage has forced
directors to cast themselves i cried
just before desert now the avengers must
band together to do what every big
franchise does when they write
themselves into a corner time travel
watch the surviving heroes dissemble for
a now that's what i call marvel tour of
your fandom with several alternate
camera angles on the avengers i'll have
that drink now a trip to the shield base
where they store all the movie's closure
thank you for everything the cliffs that
demand you lose someone you love or at
least your work bestie and a daring raid
to justify the existence of thor the
dark world in a plot held together by a
whole bunch of wibbly wobbly tommy
whammy stuff they'll try to explain 100
times either it's all a joke or none of
it is none of it's a joke now explain
yourself if you travel to the past that
past becomes your future and your former
presence becomes the past which can't
now be changed by your new future now
explain it again with a visual aid the
infinity stones create what you
experience as the flow of time remove
one of the stones
and that flow splits now explain it
again but simpler we're not trying to
stop something i'm going to do in our
time we're trying to undo something i've
already done in theirs even simpler
changing the past doesn't change the
future you know maybe time travel is a
paradox no matter how it gets justified
z
reunite with all your favorite marvel
heroes who aren't clogging up an air
filter somewhere like iron man who's
really matured since iron man 1 but is
still the a-hole who'd rather die than
let someone else get the last word i am
inevitable
and i am
iron man
captain america who after spending a
decade in the present day has learned a
curse son of a [ __ ]
and look at guys buds that is america's
ass
thor who it's okay to make fat jokes
about because he's also suffering from a
very realistic post-traumatic stress
disorder what do you think is coursing
through my veins right now she's whiz
he's struggling the hulk who cut down on
the run time by finishing his arc before
the movie starts i know it's crazy
hawkeye who deals with the loss of his
family by having a very cyberpunk
midlife crisis ant-man who thanks to the
internet's brain poisoning is a letdown
every time he's not inside thanos's ass
flick me
black widow who finally gets a primary
storyline in one of these movies killing
herself to motivate the boys we have to
make it worth it
at least you can tell the passage of
time by her hair that's something rhodey
hoping and praying they don't travel
back before iron man 2.
nebula who ruins the avengers plan so
many times the most helpful thing she
does is kill nebula
and captain marvel who's so powerful the
movie desperately finds excuses to leave
her out the things that are happening on
earth are happening everywhere so you
might not see me for a long time until
he comes up with an excuse to bring her
in
so marvel can finally have her lead the
first all-female avengers team up
shot
maybe marvel will let them team up
together in a sequel
okay maybe they can all pose again in
the background of the loki show
remember thanos the mcu's most complex
and motivated villain yet he did
and taking his place is old thanos the
new old thanos younger old thanos you
know the version who sits and lets
everyone else do all the work find the
stones what will you do
wait who steals his evil plans from
spaceballs reduce the atoms you used
them two days ago what the hell am i
looking at
when does this happen in the movie now
what did you do to them
nothing
yet go back to then when now now no i
can't why we missed it when just now and
who commands a faceless cgi army the
likes of which we have never seen before
since his last two faceless cgi armies
but whatever watching him fight
thundercat was the best moment of my
life and i'm including the birth of my
children guys sorry kids you're just not
worthy of my time and attention
so in a world where everyone hates game
of thrones now everyone's worried about
star wars and jk rowling won't stop
crapping on the floor for legacy it's a
minor miracle we got a satisfying
conclusion to a global nerd franchise
now just do it again forever or the
entire film industry will collapse no
sympathy from us disney you did this to
yourself
starring
iron deficient man
one punch woman captain clench
[Music]
and hardly wait i i'm roots
bojack norsemen
jeremy renner's one big line of acting
go grab your hammer and you go flying
you talk to him go downstairs go help
they need you right now we need more
russos give me more russos avengers
assemble
hazy ex-girlfriend
werther's original avenger
and ratman and time ben coming soon to
disney plus
i love you 2.8 billion
oh my god her mobile plan is still
active clint you gotta turn off autopay
man
[Music]
from the studios who act like divorced
parents arguing over where their kid
spends christmas comes an mcu catch-up
movie that's all about the tony
stark-shaped hole in the universe uh are
we sure disney even wants to make a
spider-man movie you're not iron man
you're never gonna be iron man
spider-man far from home
marvel fans everywhere prepare to get a
feature-length dopamine rush off that
sweet sweet intra-franchise consistency
featuring tons of iron man loads of end
game they called it the blip juicy
kernels of phase four i thought tree
having sleeper cells was top-secret
information
i feel like i'm forgetting something oh
yeah spider-man goes on vacation
please know
the concept seems a little disney plus
to me um wake me up when he gets to
space wakanda
in between setting up the next episode
of mcu hop aboard the kind of teen euro
road trip sex romp not seen since euro
trip road trip or sex drive ah don't
vote
where you'll be joined by his very own
stifler what about our plan american
bachelors in europe two teachers plugged
from a 90s sitcom they join forces like
the power rangers you're thinking of
voltron
voltron you're thinking of voltron
[Applause]
and mary jane the why a reboot of debbie
downer i'm glad we're doing this you
used to execute people on this bridge
so powers tomorrow go to the eiffel
tower i read it was secretly built as a
mind control antenna to create an army
of the insane
[Music]
you want to watch a movie
only if it's depressing
she seems nice i just hope she doesn't
end up like his other girlfriends my
wife and i split up whatever's going on
with you i hope you figure it out
watch spider-man gain a powerful new
ally from the multiverse known as
mysterio
mysterio mother you think we don't know
the guy in the sinister six is gonna be
the villain like they're gonna spend the
whole movie fighting a wave
jake gyllenhaal shines as a fishbowl
with haunted house powers who's out for
revenge on tony stark you know the
already dead guy
because even in death iron man is the
only force powerful enough to motivate
an mcu bad guy dude's company was like
an arc reactor for haters our former
boss tony stark
just get a job at hammer industries at
dorks
[Applause]
[Music]
thrill as mysterio plays on spider-man's
only weakness getting hit in the face
with a train
just kidding he's fine don't be
ridiculous no he'll strike at the one
thing peter likes most of all an adult
male who isn't perving out on his hand
hey mate how you doing what are you
wearing something skimpy i hope how's
your eye out
you look lovely new dress uh yeah yes it
is sticky rice pudding well we didn't
order that somehow
watch mysterio play on his trust to
steal edith a global drone assassination
program that tony left to a teenager
which fine that's kind of his thing
activating instant kill no no no no no
but this murder machine is hidden inside
a pair of sunglasses that's the world's
most commonly lost item he might as well
give him a pen full of ebola
oh my god thank you so much it was on
the floor
so get ready for the third spider-man 2
which perfectly sets up a second
spider-man 3. i thought that was over
that audiences won't see until feige's
schedule clears up in 2024 but no
whining because at the right state with
sony you get a spider-man movie every
year plus one with venom one with jared
leto's morbius madame webb
yeah it's probably better this way
starring
let me see that time
that time to tom tom chill and hall and
let god sort them out zendaria la la la
la la
trick fury
90 day tome fiance
uh-oh nobody tell that may about happy
and black widow
flash
make him hobgoblin you cowards
only begun this strong war has
and every non-mcu filmmaker you can be
the smartest guy in the room the most
qualified and no one cares unless you're
flying around with a cape or shooting
lasers from your hands no one will even
listen
the boy was friends with iron man
you know who loki has the darkest
backstory in the mcu flash thompson
could mother not make it
your son almost died like twice you
monster
do you like tv shows how about a tv show
about some tv shows about some tv shows
that is a tv show watched by the
characters inside a tv show
wanda vision the tv show
you said huh when they bonded over their
vaguely defined superpowers i'm still
me i think
do you know i don't know what this is
you said oh okay when they it for two
years off camera wonder for two years we
stormed these moments and you thought
well i guess that's over when this
happened
but ever since cap left bucky for this
homewrecker wanda and vision are the
closest thing marvel has to a healthy
relationship even though she's torturing
a small town with her mind when you let
us sleep
we have your nightmares your grief is
poisoning us and he's her imaginary
vibrator programmed only to love you
can't control me the way you do them
can't i
watch this power couple cosplay through
some of history's most delightful
sitcoms from modern family it's probably
just a case of the mondays to malcolm in
the middle mom's been weird since uncle
pietro got here to the show's boomers
love because they literally had no other
options take out the papers and the
trash
or you won't get no spending cash but
every once in a while this super
computer manages to calculate something
about all this might not be on the up
and up i have questions what is it how
did this happen she came here because
we're all what what was that about what
aren't you telling me why are there no
other children in wesley
why would you think that i guess you are
[Music]
because the big question of the series
isn't so much what's gonna happen but
more what the [ __ ] is even happening i
don't know i don't know and i don't know
in a story that's really about wanda's
grief and finding acceptance the
acceptance that no matter how original a
marvel thing starts off it still has to
end with a sky beam and two cgi dolls
throwing particle effects at each other
it's just so meaningful this reminds me
of my own struggles i'm sorry i just
need a second
but there's more to the show than an
expanding red bubble of sadness that
makes america great again step outside
the hex to meet characters like darcy
the latest phase of marvel's image rehab
campaign for thor the dark world
jimmy wu the only cop who's also into
close-up magic that anyone could ever
love and monica rambo who grows from a
knowing commentary on tv's black best
friend trope into an actual example of
tv's black best friend trove they'll
never know what you sacrificed for them
and finally into a superhero who could
one day become marvel's first black best
friend trope in space
together they'll take on some brand new
villains like this generic military jerk
ass dottie who actually thought it
doesn't really matter and the head which
in charge agatha harkness a well-brewed
concoction of one part maleficent and
two parts cruella de vil and i killed
sparky too
[Laughter]
let your love for katherine han blind
you to the fact that her plan doesn't
make a ton of sense and her past implies
that the salem witch trials were kind of
onto something and despite what her
absolute bop of the theme song claims
[Music]
she barely knows what's going on either
i need you to tell me how you did this i
couldn't make heads or tails of it it's
been wonders repressed trauma all along
but agatha kind of nuts turned that
direction doesn't exactly top the charts
though huh
are you a hardcore marvel fan then you
know wandavision wasn't meant to be
enjoyed but dissected frame by frame to
predict what's coming next as the show
spawned a q anon style army of
forecasters who were so sure that
mephisto was behind it all the devil's
in the details bev that's not the only
place he is
nope just a deep cut easter egg evan
peters casting was proof of the
multiverse
wrong just an elaborate boner joke boner
and that the last episode had to have a
luke skywalker level cameo i work with
this actor that i have always wanted to
work with oh
and
we have
fireworks together
how about paul bernie giving himself
head instead
why can't you just accept the fact that
the big bad for the mcu's first disney
plus series was grief does [ __ ] you have
to spell it out on an announcement board
or something
so if you've been feeling sad and
hopeless lately and just want to
mentally check out and fill all the
voids in your life with garbage tv catch
the story of a superhero who does pretty
much exactly that and at the end of the
day after all the trauma follow her to
the place all marvel characters go once
their arcs are done
some lonely ass cabin in the woods
[Music]
storing
i'm a witch i'm a mother an avenger had
a brother wanda's no scrunch
i'll see you what curtain call that was
radical
get the skin thing cuddles and kisses
between his little ears weekend at bed
knees what white nonsense is this agatha
crispy
a spectrum representative will arrive
anytime between the hours of 1 and 9 pm
boner save the cat whose clues
wrecking ralph the only way ralph would
remember our anniversary is if there was
a beer named june 2nd what ralph could
really use is how to goose your wife so
you don't lose your wife ralph looks
better in the dark so i'm not
complaining not that ralph ever wants to
eat anything other than baked beans
which explains a lot about his personal
appeal mind you you sure you don't want
an audience volunteer named my husband
ralph oh
hey where'd you blow me
wanda's twin powers activate going
through hex
and what is this show if not joy
disappearing do you have a brother mom
he's
far away from here and that makes me
sad sometimes he was killed by ultron
maria died three years ago before what i
can't remember my life before west virgo
i don't know who i am you probably
suppressed a lot of the trauma you're so
crippled by your own self-doubt all you
people who left still have the luxury of
optimism you have no idea what it was
like oh it's lost i only remember
feeling completely alone
endless nothingness so much trauma is it
khan will be sorrow can it parents dead
brother dead
vision dead i have a daughter if you
could just let her out of her room if i
could just hold her i can't feel you
thanks for choosing me to be your mom
[Music]
if one ever needs backup she should just
call her neighbor murtaugh from lethal
weapon i'm too old for this
[Music]
from the streaming service with the
biggest gap between quality of content
and suckage of interface comes marvel's
latest avengers you didn't really care
about until they got their own tv show
the falcon and the winter soldier
who's next hawkeye
of course
when a rogue super soldier is on the
loose the only thing that can stop her
is a few shots from a regular gun
but since the story has to last six
episodes two of marvel's weakest heroes
are on the case sam the falcon wilson a
man with the power of a jet pack he
rents from the air force
and bucky the winter soldier barns
proof that men will literally scour the
criminal safe haven of matripore instead
of going to therapy you missed your
court mandated therapy sorry mr barnes
you're under arrest but when these not
even that opposite military guys have to
work together you'll be in for a lot of
forced bickering that's not a thing
that's definitely it no it's not a lot
of forced quips now that falcon is
technically the funny one and he
mastered posing stoic
and so much forced talk about cap's old
shield that you'll start to wish cap was
short for please decapitate me thank you
captain america but this belongs to you
let's take the shield and do this
ourselves you got to give me the shield
man he gave you that shield for a reason
why'd you give up that shield he had no
right to give up the shield sam
shouldn't have given him the shield i
didn't give him the shield that
the closest thing i've got left to a
family
it's just a shield bro don't lose your
arm over it
you know you think he would know that
there's a button that pops his arm off i
mean doesn't he ever play with that
thing
return to the military espionage side of
the mcu where the morals are as grey as
the visuals full of shady characters
like semo a fancy dancer who talks about
the black experience one too many times
for someone who blew up the king of
wakanda i told him about trouble man he
wrote in that book it is a masterpiece
james it captures the african-american
experience
sharon carter who's grown bitter and
resentful since the man she stalked for
a living went back in time to bang her
great aunt and john walker the heir
apparent to the kool-aid guy
oh yeah
he may look the part but this
blond-haired honk still isn't ready to
take on the mantle of america's next
kurt russell also julie louie dreyfus
pops up at the end because everyone in
hollywood is obligated to join the mcu
at this point your next costanza this
whole universe is against me
no one will escape the fury of the flag
smashers a movement with a nefarious
plan to deliver food and medicine to
refugees but don't worry they'll kill
just enough people to qualify as
villains i agree with your fight i just
can't give it the way you're fighting it
you tell him falcon she needs to join
the military first that's the mcu's
license to kill to combat his rising
threat of poor people having nowhere to
live sea must become a new kind of
captain america one who will call out
the problems with our system if you
people have just as much power as an
insane god then ask them to do better
and hope that it changes anything you've
got to do better senator honestly the
fact that this beach works is the least
realistic part of the mcu and they share
a universe with this
[Music]
guy so enjoy a show that feels like a
stretched out b-tier marvel movie that
annoyingly makes you stay up late to
watch every episode unless you want it
spoiled on twitter
ah dang it in this enjoyable series that
deepens existing characters bring some
big budget action to the small screen
and add crucial new information to the
marvel universe the avengers don't get
paid
how do you guys make a living there's a
tremendous amount of goodwill right but
you could have been living off of
goodwill this whole time we cannot
approve you is there some kind of fun
for heroes or so this is why scarlet
witch drives a bug
starring
the black falcon was denied a bank loan
i stan sebastian
barron's dance grooves
[Music]
the carter two
a wolf in veeps clothing
goldie spawn just when i thought this
country couldn't get any meaner you go
and do something like this
and totally redeem yourself
power punch girl
oh it's those antiva super soldiers i've
been hearing about
and
sam's on the boat sends on a boat
everybody look at sam cause he's sailing
on a boat
sam's on the boat sam's on a boat take a
good hard look at sam's sister's parents
boat
sky captain and the shield of tomorrow
let's do it let's stare they're
practically begging us to do a stairs
montage huh
[Music]
are you having a staring contest the
bionic staring machine is always a stare
like that
wait good the music no no no no you
can't stare bait us like that your
stairs are too forced stairs have to be
natural you're doing the staring thing
again
[Music]
they've done heart-wrenching
examinations of pain and grief
meditations on america's betrayal of
black soldiers but now a marvel series
is ready to take on life's biggest
question
how long would it take for you to do
yourself
about a week tops right
loki
now that marvel's killed off its only
good villains they'll turn back in time
to pluck loki from the avengers dress
him like he's in a ska band and do a
speed run through three movies worth of
character development
i love you my sons
remember this place
but honestly i'm glad they made the show
tom hiddleston hasn't been this charming
since that pov chinese vitamin
commercial probably be a bit busy for
the next few weeks
but um
i'll make it up to you soon i promise is
he supposed to be my husband or are we
having an affair either way i'm in
follow loki's journey through space and
time to escape the clutches of the tva a
bunch of time cops tasked with the
sacred duty to try and make the word
prune happen they want to personally
oversee the variance pruning tva has
pruned a lot of these guys prune on site
no no pruning she's already been pruned
just prune it let's bail so you're gonna
prune me or he pruned her prune it prune
him she's self prone watch them clean up
the mcu timeline with a ruthless
efficiency of kevin feige murdering a
netflix series because apparently the
only version of events that's allowed to
happen is the one where a rat saves half
of existence and captain america goes
back in time to beat his own ass
take a number tommy boy because this
isn't just a showcase for one loki
there's an entire comic-con's worth of
variants to cosplay as like sylvie the
femme fatale who spent her life camping
out in various ragnaroks making it hard
for her to trust someone i can't sleep
around untrustworthy people what was i
thinking trusting you because you can't
trust
and i can't be trusted and even harder
for her to open up to the possibility
that she might just want to do herself
and i mean come on most people do
themselves every day like multiple times
a day and the timeline is just fine
trust me
there's classic loki proving that
richard e grant can make you love any
character even if he's dressed like
kermit the frog and talking nonsense for
30 minutes straight kid loki who
murdered thor but like kid thor all you
have to do is dangle a candy bar near a
wood chipper and let nature take its
course alligator loki he is an alligator
and chinese vitamin commercial loki
what you can't tell me that's not an
extremely health conscious loki variant
i mean just look at how many vegetables
you make me for breakfast oh hiyo nida
they're joined by mobius a bureaucrat
who's obsessed with loki and jet skis
which makes him the perfect partner for
the man who's also obsessed with loki's
and jet skis c
jetski
then there's judge rinslayer an evil
bureaucrat who discovers that she's
actually middle management not upper
middle management like she thought
gasp miss minutes just one of many
multimedia presentations the show has to
use to explain what's going on without
your eyes glazing over
your salad
is asgard no don't do
and kang the conquerors annoying theater
kid variant journey to the hogwarts at
the end of the universe to meet marvel's
next bad guy with a thing for purple and
thrill as after five episodes of
fast-paced excitement kang plops into
the series like the architect from
matrix 2 if he also did improv he can't
kill me because
i already know what's going to happen i
every human
[Music]
and ages
of cosmic harmony this scene is 11
minutes long
when marvel needed to get trippy they
called up rick and morty writer michael
waldron to run the show and he's
bringing along a grab bag of wildly
original concepts like portal guns space
lizards space lizards barely escaping
planets before they're destroyed
speeches about how existence is chaos
existence is chaos nobody exists on
purpose
nobody belongs anywhere everybody's
gonna die hive minds me i presume if
anyone's anyone
you're me my passion for unification you
mean stealing people's bodies summer
rude tech that's always running out of
jews
characters very precisely and cunningly
breaking each other down psychologically
insecure need for validation would
motivate you to find the killer you act
like prey but you're a predator you use
pity to lure in your victims that's how
you survive getting drunk during big
missions you're drunk no
i'm just full but bear in mind
i'm very full and time prison you know
what they do to third dimensional life
forms in time prison same thing they do
in every other prison only forever wow
where do they get all these ideas i
guess there was nothing left to steal
from jack kirby huh
strap in for what's ultimately a small
scale series that manages to feel huge
thanks to massive animated establishing
shots like when you witness the
apocalypse of this world from an empty
crater enter an infernal nightmare
bureaucracy that stretches to infinity
now let's retire to this office and
welcome to the void at the center of
time and reality the quick into their
bowling alley
so if you're ready to be stuck with
content like a foie gras goose enjoy the
show that gets you ready for a movie
that gets you ready for the next wave of
the mcu that gets you ready for season
two of the show
that gets you ready for death and as
long as they keep making v-plus content
while keeping every good actor from
doing anything original this machine is
going to keep cranking until we're all
in water world darkest timeline
starring
low-key on god
loki a lady to knife the setting
crashers bf kangs the old guard
he who rehashes
gators will say it's fake dramatic
weapon uncheating for my next trick
love
is a dagger find a way back to the tva
fine
here
betrayals i've never stabbed him in the
back that's such a boring form of
betrayal judge wren slayer really feel
betrayed by her beloved tba i guess you
don't do partners unless of course it
benefits you and you intend to betray
them at some point how do i know that in
the final moments you won't betray me
you betrayed me no no you betrayed me
you betrayed me you betrayed me oh grow
up grow up apologies my liege i betrayed
you about that
you can't be serious my throne about
that
and hair flips
chrono trigger
you know this never would have happened
if tony stark had just let hulk use the
elevator he really is responsible for
every bad thing in this universe
[Music]
she helped tony get his mojo back
helped bruce reconnect with his humanity
helped cap find his true purpose and
helped hawkeye uh
keep being hawkeye baby you want to go
talk to him okay go grab your hammer and
you go flying you talk to him
but now natasha finally gets to tell her
own story about the time she helped her
own replacement join the mcu
black widow
you've been waiting to see the mcu's
first female superhero get her own movie
and waiting
and waiting but natasha romanov is
finally getting the mid-tier solo marvel
movie she deserves because the ultimate
sign of respect in pop culture is
getting your chance to keep important
object x out of the hands of military
leader y by taking down massive airship
z i know marvel's taking some risks here
and there but this one definitely sticks
to the old plan so
this was the big plan huh i like your
plan except it sucks so let me do the
plan we need a plan of attack i have a
plan
attack first of all you're copying me
from when i said i had a plan what about
our plan american bachelors in europe
that's your plan that's a solo plan come
on this is my plan my plan was to drive
us away it's the plan
get to know the real natasha romanoff a
woman struggling to overcome the trauma
of being a child actor i remember this
day we shot christmas thanksgiving
easter and summer vacation all on monday
she's got nothing but her wits and flips
to protect her in a dangerous world of
super spies although at some point she
entered the cheat code that turns off
environmental damage
uh
what and for one scene she turns into
mega man but they never mention it again
what
journey to russia where everyone speaks
with their best uh let's call it
sokovian accent or just doesn't even try
i was the family reunion unless you're
actually from eastern europe in which
case you are mute and me the surrogate
family who raised black widow back in
her 90s ghost world phase there's red
guardian david harbor's latest attempt
to hide in a siberian prison until
everyone forgets about the hellboy
remake molina a monster war criminal who
tortures pigs
and played a willing active role in
kidnapping little girls and brainwashing
them into fembots but she regrets it so
no harm no foul mama take care of
yourself okay
don't worry i got this
and elena the mischievous little braided
hair sister from little women who's now
the mischievous little braided hair
sister who's murdered untold hundreds of
people i'm not the killer that little
girls call their hero i don't know elena
say three cute things about your vest
and i'll take a whole russian prison's
worth of dead bodies off your ledger it
has a lot of pockets
but i use them all the time and i made
some of my own modifications i know how
much you like it does have a lot of
pockets very handy pockets yeah it's so
cool right it's good yes and you can put
so much stuff in there you wouldn't even
know oh she likes the vest so cute
this would be a cool way to die
i'm sure they deserved it
thrill at a story that dares to ask what
if the most powerful force on earth girl
power fell into the wrong hands
as the evil mastermind harvey weinstein
i mean drake off builds a floating
fortress that evades detection because
it's cloudy and uses the power of his
colossal stank to keep him
safe prevents you from committing
violence against me he's infiltrated the
halls of power with a sister soldier
hood of mind-controlled assassins and
doing his evil bidding is the taskmaster
a martial artist with the ability to
mimic any hero's moves but none of their
personality or charisma
because now that marble has themselves a
deadpool someone had to become the
deadpool from wolverine origins
so if you're looking for a left nikita
but a lot or what if charlie's angels
but evil or what if propaganda was used
to twist trafficked young girls towards
the nefarious purposes of the rich and
powerful including bill clinton and
condoleezza rice but like could also be
a ride at disneyland
then strap in for a movie that's good at
being pretty much everything except a
black widow solo film
starring
sister traitor soldier spy
florence and the regime
super bored
the manservant's tale oh a y spy eh
babe pig in the study
boy bruff nicole me drake golfing
the hurt stalker
the winter sold her
mini
venice the menace and the most brutal
murder in black widow's history you've
always been a really good friend to me
in soviet russia m sees you
wow i wonder which full-grown adult
managed to lose a tic-tac-toe
hawkeye definitely hall guy
[Music]
from the studio you know the one there's
only like two of them left now anyways
comes a series based on silly comic
books like what if iron man fought king
arthur or what if wolverine was a
vampire that dares to imagine something
even more ridiculous what if mcu riders
could try something new
but not like new new just a slight remix
of some old favorites let's not go too
crazy here
marvel's what if enjoy some wild
animated experiments that stay true to
the mcu by having no real beginning or
end no real message to get behind and
every character from the most hardened
warrior to the most powerful cosmic
being speaks like an ai barfing out
chandler bing dialogue i simply abort
drama your outfit would suggest
otherwise
uh
guys i'm covered in sharon
do you guys just not have horror movies
in wakanda we don't need them we have
american reality shows boom goes the
dynamite
right now you're running at an eight and
i need you to take it down to a four
your team visiting instincts
yeah
okay i don't sound like that that is so
not true
that happened
meet the watcher the other extremely
powerful comics character who swore
never to intervene in human affairs that
we're meeting this fall
hi
he's a messy [ __ ] who lives for drama
and this jeffrey right-shaped
planetarium will guide you through
alternate timelines like what if england
had a pop culture icon who wasn't a
sociopath what if every franchise was
better without chris pratt what if all
the avengers died and also agent coulson
was a five on the kinsey scale he's a
caucasian male mid-20s with really great
hair it's an accurate description he's
gorgeous hashtag
steve steve steve i heart steve even
while rotting he smells like lavender
what if the universe had it out for
rachel mcadams you know doctor what's
her face what if she was the key to all
of this any interest what if zombies you
guys still like zombies right sorta okay
how about this one what if killmonger
the most sympathetic villain in the
entire mcu was just destined to become
evil like no matter what someone should
have killed him in his crib what do you
mean this isn't working for you fine
we'll do it your way what if ultron
stole vision and chopped off thanos arm
and ate the universe and was like whoa
i'm gonna eat you too and the watcher
had to be like not on my watch and they
start punching and avengers fall down
the robots get hit with the shields
again okay wait you good do you little
content piggies get what you came for
come on why are you crying oh right this
is a show for kids i forget that
sometimes
kick back and listen to find out which
of your favorite actors needed to pick
up an extra check during covid don't
play the fool with me fury michael
douglas really then get genuinely choked
up when you realize you're hearing
chadwick boseman do t'challa for the
last time it doesn't feel over and
finally wonder what dave batista did
that caused disney not even reach out
all right principles but regardless
thrill has a bunch of million dollar
voices emerge from heroes who look like
the characters you pay 10 bucks for at a
town fair because walt disney's built
its entire brand on top quality
animation everyone deserves a break now
and then it's been a tough year are we
sure they didn't buy dreamworks too
you know what's hot right now the
multiverse and after endgame helped set
up the idea of the multiverse and one
division teased the possibilities of the
multiverse and loki explained the scope
of the multiverse and doctor strange too
gives us multiverse madness what if
we'll drive the message of the
multiverse home even further we're all
one of an infinite number of variants
going through the same
our struggle seen only by a voyeuristic
space walnut who could save us from our
fates at any time but won't wow there
had to be an easier way than killing
free will to explain why terence howard
can't play roadie anymore or whatever he
thinks one times one is two
so if you want to see your favorite
marvel characters and exciting new
stories that stretch the imagination buy
a comic book but if you want more of the
things you already liked combined with
other things you already liked resulting
in something slightly less than the sum
of its parts well what if there was
nothing else to watch until eternals
comes out
wow
look at him stand there can't wait
starring
i only watch the multiverse for the
articles you captain america
the cat is the pratt someone please take
this man's driver's license
[Music]
glove death and robots halloween three
season of the witch scarlet no hansen
gundam wang
futurama did it
asgardian pie pricario
hentai squid and this is what happens
when you mess with a mouse robert
you have to die
but why
[Music]
male ducks have corkscrew penises just
putting that out there i now pronounce
you darcy and a duck
[Music]
disney gave cap and tony chinese cell
phones replaced a tibetan hero with
tilda swinton and thanked prison camp
bureaucrats at the end of mulan but now
the magic kingdom will pander to the
middle kingdom by making a pretty
kick-ass martial arts movie okay it's
better than that time they dropped a
full episode of er shanghaine iron man 3
[Music]
color paper
i am shocked this wasn't in the american
cut
chongqi
for the very first time the mcu is
bringing a martial arts master from the
comics to the screen
yep the very first time the iron fist
sorry can't hear you as audiences
finally get to know shanghai a guy whose
most relatable quality is that he's also
getting to know shanghi who are you your
mother knew who she was do you who the
hell are you i'm not
who you think i am
just like spider-man he's a parker with
a secret identity because underneath his
obligatory abs beats the heart of a
martial arts master
martial arts expert
martial arts enthusiast but nothing will
come between this one punch manchild and
the ultimate power fantasy no not
joining the avengers kicking your
father's ass
punch
the mcu's greatest threat has returned
bad dads tony long shines as the most
seamless example yet of digitally
de-aged actors what do you mean he still
looks like that well not bad kneel
before this ancient warlord who still
doesn't know the difference between
rings and bracelets who gave up all his
power for a lady who blew him in the
woods
in addition to his ten magic bracelets
he also commands the ten rings a secret
group like hydra or shield or sword or
the scrolls or the hand or the eternals
but what sets them apart from marvel's
other illuminatis and presumably
marvel's illuminati is that the ten
rings provide exciting new opportunities
in the world of evil franchising he
appropriated the ten rings my tan rings
open up a 10 rings in a country near you
we're more than just an evil franchise
we're an evil family twenty percent cash
down payment required
journey to tahloe presumably the
inspiration for ancient chinese legends
ancient middle earth legends
and legendary pokemon for a film that
blends the action comedy of a jackie
chan flick with a high-flying combat of
wusha and the cgi toilet slurry of a
marvel third act
because while an emotional expertly
choreographed martial arts showdown
between father and son is cool isn't it
way cooler when a bunch of weightless
polygons smash into each other
no then why does it keep happening
sean won't have to fight alone he's
joined by his sister ja ling who learned
to fight just by auditing classes at
murder university trevor slatterly who
pissed nerds off so much in iron man 3
that his only friend is a psychic
chicken made out of butts where's his
face
psychic by chicken
and aquafina who pulls off four classic
marvel roles at the same time platonic
love interest reaction face giver
the that just happened sidekick a guy
with a freaking machete foreign arm just
chopped our butts in half shawn used the
10 rings to like do this like crazy
kamehameha fireball that exploded the
thing that dragon
vomited a magical water map
and now i have no idea what's real and
hawkeye
upgrade
so for a franchise whose roots are an
openly racist money grab enjoy a film
that does its part to smash those
stereotypes except the one about asian
dudes being the biggest sneaker heads in
this solid martial arts fantasy flick
full of fun characters that refreshingly
stands on its own without resorting to
crossovers and team ups until after the
credits of course they don't match any
artifacts from our codex they're not
vibranium not like any alien tech i've
seen this could have been an email
starring
destiny's child soldier
ring pop
house of flying swagger the human
calendar we've been friends for 10 years
okay you know i'm not an idiot i've been
by your side for half your life your dad
trained you to be an assassin when you
were seven he sent you on a hit
at 14. can you punch with all the colors
of the wind deputy dog
i'm sorry your name is it's razorfist
ant-man
render the last dragon your soul is mine
a normal day on the sf metro and how
marvel casts its male heroes
love that guy
i'll take your shirt off
once upon a time in a china adjacent
pocket dimension
hmm so shanghi works with cars he's not
proud of who he used to be and he has a
difficult relationship with his dad
something about that backstory seems
convenient
in a world where a bankrupt comic book
company sold the film rights to its best
characters for peanuts because they
thought movies would be a good way to
show more comics a young executive will
do what he can with the rejects that no
one wanted and do so well they get
bought out by disney before it was cool
the marvel cinematic universe
except for in game
welcome to the mcu a tv series made of
movies about comic books where magic is
actually science your ancestors called
it magic and you call it science but not
by magic by technology magic
science but science is basically magic
boy boy scouts of america is a
worthwhile organization i didn't
physically check the crates and meet
your typical mcu protagonist a loner
with no pets no biological siblings and
whose only friends are their co-workers
oh whose personality can range from
lighthearted quipster i'm sorry earth is
closed today to stern duty-bound
military type you get hurt hurt him back
you get killed
walk it off and on a long enough
timeline everyone becomes a quipster
[ __ ] please you've been to space follow
along on their hero's journeys where
after a motivating uncle ben situation
they'll get a transformational hairstyle
cut some carbs and find the strength to
boldly say their superhero name out loud
i'm
captain america i am iron man i'm thor
son of odin i'm ant-man i am group nick
fury i'm peter by the way doctor strange
oh using the made-up names um
i'm spider-man then star-lord
who
but people say a hero is only as good as
their villain and thank god that's not
true or the mcu would be hot garbage
thrill as they spare 10 minutes to
establish a bad guy who's just like the
hero but evil
or a faceless horde can't feel bad if it
doesn't have a face or actually a pretty
awesome character and they're dead but
everyone knows the real villain of the
mcu is dads he was cold he was
calculating he never told me he loved me
and never even told me he liked me you
favored thor all these years you were
wrong to turn your backs on the rest of
the world everything i heard about
myself
of course i have issues
that's my freaking father i will hunt my
father like a dog and i will tear him
apart slowly
peace by peace until he knows some
semblance of the profound and unceasing
pain i know every single day
yeah
tremble before the girth of a
meticulously planned story told across
23 separate movies all about thanos
killing half the universe well first he
has to get an infinity gauntlet no not
that god i'll do it myself yeah yeah
that one and then gather the infinity
stones well send proxies to get them and
he gives one away but eventually he'll
get the stones some aren't stones while
the other relics often appear as stones
the ether is fluid but then he'll kill
half the universe which also doesn't
make much sense oh also the timeline
doesn't work out
hmm maybe this wasn't so planned out
after all but the films do sort nicely
into three distinct phases the
conventional pop songs phase the
boundary pushing experimental phase then
the whoo we can do no wrong i'm a golden
god phase and if rock docks are topping
anything phase four will have the mcu
puking in the gutter wondering where it
all went wrong
journey from the farthest reaches of
viking space to alternate dimensions to
the wonders of earth oops that one
zootopia and marvel at how everything
still kind of looks and feels the same
as visionary indie filmmakers are
funneled into the marvel style of
overlap digital video where everything
is cgi every story is full of sexless
romance that never takes
off how what the hell bloodless violence
that never leaves more than a couple of
forehead scrapes all that for a drop of
blood lifeless soundtracks with more
dead rock and you can shake a pair of
middle-aged screenwriters at feels so
good jack manzioni 1977. marvin gaye
1972 troubleman soundtrack donald
feeling blue swede 1973 that song
belongs to me or toothless comedy that's
just saying pop culture things so this
orb has a real shiny blue suitcase arc
of the covenant maltese falcon sort of
vibe i love doing a christmas toy
shooting night rider or touring with his
band in germany no hard feelings point
break you gotta mean swing who build my
new lego death star what try me beyonce
that man is playing galaga you ever see
this really old movie aliens we're
getting no help from flash courtney i'm
very popping y'all shall we play a game
i can flush the move exactly like
footloose squidward grimace
personal flying monkeys i understood
that reference blue lagoon gandalf and
harry potter oops that's pixels
so settle in for an interconnected movie
verse that had a 1 in 14 million 605
shot of working but those odds didn't
stop every other studio from awkwardly
mashing their eyepiece together like a
junior high dance floor leaving marvel
as the only one standing in a dying
industry i could do this all day but
launching a whole new industry of marvel
movie news theory and analysis channels
that just complain about marvel movies
and even comedy web series that would
have died a long time ago if marvel
movies weren't so popular
so one way or another in the end
everyone's getting paid by disney you
shills
starring
science geniuses you can achieve heavy
eye on fusion at any reactor on the
planet quantum phases when an object
moves through different states of matter
an einstein rosenbridge is a theoretical
connection between two different points
of space the wormhole the quantum system
would revert back to separate states of
matter why didn't you just reprogram the
synapses to work collectively when did
you become an expert in thermonuclear
astrophysics last night jumping out of
airplanes
[Music]
people of color
leg scissors
[Music]
trains
howdies unless you're ant-man then you
get a hyundai and you like it dual
wielding
dick measuring i mean you have a big gun
you are not the big gun tony don't be
jealous
like
raging fire so i like smoldering fire my
record
21 feet not bad you
65 feet whoa yeah huge 65. you get an
ironman suit and you get an ironman suit
and you get an ironman suit weird
non-stanley cameos hey the oracle of
oracle good idea for an electric jet
[Applause]
multi-hit combos
[Music]
are you sure you know how to fly this
thing do you know how to fly this thing
uh we'll see i thought you said he knew
how to fly this thing
i said how hard could it be here take
the wheel no i don't know how to fly one
of these are you're a scientist use one
of your phds and never forget that for
all of guardians one they're sitting in
star lords jizz find a black light
please look like a jackson pollock
painting
ah gross dude
the never-ending story
oh man we forgot to say anything about
the abc shows netflix series one shots
and spin-offs eh so did kevin feige
this week's honest trailer is brought to
you by dnd beyond's battle for beyond
subscribe to ddb's youtube to join the
battle i am no longer the winter soldier
i am james bucky barnes and you're part
of my efforts to make amends
do i look like i need your power